I think it's pretty clear that the
media's concern is in America's safety
but obviously they're trying to get
their worldview out there that trumps
America's a bunch of angry racist white
men with tiki torches doing pretty well
if this is Trump's racist Amer yeah what
do you think about well why are you
covering this I thought all of America
was a twenty or thirty at this Meetup
question of the day why do you think the
media is so dead set on vilifying
straight white males and in downplaying
the real dangers of ugly ideologies and
we can we can document we will in this
segment that it's happening in posit
theories but why do you think it's a
case comment below I want to hear from
you
of course this ties into the unite the
right rally even though I don't think
any of us got the memo poorly more of a
meet yeah really poorly more organized
meetups about twenty or thirty white
supremacist who met up March this
weekend along with hundreds of cops
hundreds members of media and thousands
of ants for members of course who were
threatening to beat up said cops and the
media and I had my I have my Google
Holmes and have three liberal sources
first in the morning so my news always
comes from the left first and you would
have not known that this was a very tiny
rally at force because it kept
referencing Charlottesville what
happened terrible obviously last year
and no reference Avantika whatsoever so
of course also by the way no reference
to this girl are you you're not you're
not even counter protesting cuz you're
basically just standing and it continues
gonna make sure they know that I'm your
actions
yeah that's the serious she also sounds
Canadian by the way to be fair she did
think that she was talking to Rocky in
movie three with a megaphone yeah
someone getting shy with a pedal assist
bike yeah she could use some new clothes
does she should declare Marshalls
law by the way she goes on to say this
same boy's mother got my give her last
three tinder dates who stopped calling
for some reason
just kidding shame adding a date with a
man I think her poison is corn syrup
oh I don't know that's not mean it's not
sweat it's not I'm not it's probably
accurate but it is mean I have to an
extra 20 pounds of syrup on me right now
I live the dream I get it nice nice save
there like I applied it to a clearly
mentally [ __ ] woman but now if I use
she was doing a scene from King Lear to
answer by the way my previous question I
think it's pretty clear that the media's
concern is in America's safety but
obviously they're trying to get their
worldview out there that Trump's
America's a bunch of angry racist white
men with tiki torches versus a peaceful
coalition of immigrants Muslims
extremists and genderqueer transsexuals
but by the way doing pretty well if this
is Trump's racist Amer yeah what do you
think about well why are you covering
this I thought all of America was a
twenty or thirty at this Meetup yeah
that's what we were told initially
here's something you can tell it by
three things they do the media as far as
urgent so what number one is they they
always emphasize whenever they can find
white supremacist violence and this is
more than what about ISM so the unites
the right rally of course received
massive coverage massive coverage
despite having an attendance today it's
comperable to a ninth ninth grade
birthday party cousin wine tastings that
are bigger than that yes exactly I was
like Orca watching and there's the same
amount of orcas yes there's the orcas
they're white supremacists who just due
to like need attention to do there was a
if you need attention and you want to
feel like a precious boy you become a
white supremacist and be like all the
ante fair looking at me Brian or a
member of the or a member of the
Westboro Baptist Church News Senate
press roof good boy there's about 14
members Jenna flippers because they're
all doing it with their sisters and they
get prepped I mean how often do we hear
about the Westboro back way way way too
often
no one cares that's a good
representative you know why cuz the
other word Baptists in their name so by
the way again so this is Trump's racist
America too doesn't turn up that's a
really good sign everybody got right
direction and another than they do of
course is a scrub stories and expose
dangers of radical Islam so well of
course the journalists were covering
this this tiny tiny reality there was a
bombshell story of a New Mexico as Islam
asustor to training children to commit
school shootings did you read this story
right yeah
yeah it's incredible nobody nobody I saw
it on Twitter and almost nowhere else
and it wouldn't say Muslim it was like
rakhna be Muhammad du bois it was just a
random guy slash Anderson
ya know their training school show
teachers but no the fact that I own a
rifle is the problem because David hog
is on rollerblades and he said by the
way he's 18 now so you can say whatever
you want no I did when I when he was 17
I brought it you want to bring it to me
I'll bring it to you these you're right
though actually we check back on the
initial stories from these new sources
they completely omitted references to
Islam or or the compounds ties like you
said yeah and I always say man if you
compare the Toronto shooting from my
home country of course seen in the kept
hammering the banning of handguns was
something they were talking about a lot
the mental health issues of course get
trotted back out didn't know that he was
a Muslim shooter who visited Isis web
sites prior they took an Isis by the way
claimed responsibility for the shooting
that should have been a tip-off like it
was national white man it was not the
white man it was us we real bad hashtag
bad dudes can he come on get out of the
way for a second I think there are 30
people to march on Washington it was
just female lesbian Trainspotting just
screaming and panting still responsible
for 92% of all tear related deaths by
the way Islam in case you're one is
comes from Cato compare that by the way
to the deaths of at the hands of white
supremacists it's not even close
no and the Charlottesville guy was just
a random schizophrenic dude who just
freaked out they never talk about the
Charlottesville guy or the Vegas shooter
do you notice that well yeah because it
was the same with that shooting at that
up that newspaper remember they were
like Miley Annapolis motivated someone
on the right and that turns out was just
something like dude who like hated a
girl and then no one talked about it
again yeah it was just like once they
realize it isn't the narrative they want
it's just gone remember YouTube gone
they're like oh it's it's uh yeah it's a
weird vegan lady likes pandas yeah no I
had nothing then no I can we talk again
about the schizophrenic with the car yes
cuz that's all they got because uh NRA
members don't shoot up places there that
no no that was the one guy we had here
what did our show first was uh willow
Stephen Wilford saw the one Springs
that's
was more deadly than parkland and no one
ever actually talked about it no one
wants to talk about it all because a guy
was an NRA instructor who stopped a bad
guy with an ar-15 so another thing to do
number three you see from the media a
lot as ad emphasize left-wing violence
as a protest so a good example of this
event here which I'm at the unite the
right rally no you know you could white
supremacist I think we're all on board
bad yeah certainly hit some of the dodge
charger that's terrible very bad but
it's a buzz kill let's look at am de for
the left-wing protesters there who
repeatedly said they would kill Trump if
given the champ the beat police officers
they damage equipment and the attack
journalists it's caught on tape here's
the worst part about this is how to CNN
frame the Antipas story look at this
clip from the CNN anchor right now voice
this vow to hate and racism are mixing
with voices spouting justice and
equality and so far thankfully it is
just words that are clashing why destroy
your on the field a portion of the bus
we're gonna send you down to the field
here for the unite the right rally okay
what if I get dragged out and beaten up
an acid attack like you're gonna cover
that you're gonna avenge me right yeah
well train it will change your name to
Hitler it will we find the network will
be covered what about me evil now here's
what the big it's not just the what
about ISM and we we always get fresh way
with this when they do with Hillary
Clinton and what okay let me let me kind
of paint the big picture here for you
what really scares me these people CNN
these same people who are doing the same
kind of coverage in a regular basis
they're in charge of determining what is
fake news or real yet these completely
biased media Titans are the ones
partnering with social media gens to
promote real news in silence alternative
media that's what's so scary to me
people who see the Alex Jones situation
what do you agree with him or not
yeah I see a lot of people saying that
corporations are just becoming
extensions of the government and they're
effectively the ones doing the the
censoring it seems quite a bit asthmatic
I think what's his name from The Young
Turks knows I'm Joe Rogan uh he's left
to think Jim is it jimmy dore jimmy dore
the decent one yeah you're he was trauma
how they're kind of this extension the
corporation of the government and okay
i'm on a second think about this if
that's true Donald Trump wasn't Alex
Jones fan Silicon Valley
he ain't gonna meet all that much to
them right no love lost for Donald Trump
so if you believe that corporations are
an extension of government again these
people there's a there could not have
been a deep platforming wherever you
went up of Alex Jones of iTunes Spotify
YouTube Facebook Twitter right all at
once without some kind of collusion and
that's the thing there's this little
kernel where people talk about
Illuminati meetings these crazy
conspiracies but then when you see that
hole on the sky was removed from every
single major platform within 12 hours of
each other all of them of course there
has to be collusion and now there's
justification for the paranoia and you
make conspiracy theorists more popular
than ever same thing happen to me when I
was banned for life off Twitter I got
banned that same day off YouTube and I
realized why it is - and why they do it
- Jones because a lot of times they
don't link would eat what they're saying
they just say something they're like
he's full of hate and bigotry and he
attacked a unicorn but they don't show
you because and then they want to take
away your video so that you can tell
that means he did say a lot of stuff oh
yeah yeah yeah but this happened -
something with with a crowd of confronts
video in Austin they did a whole
play-by-play of the video but they never
actually show you the video and that's
sign that I think everyone should be
looking for whether you're right or left
is transparency if if you consistently
tuned into a media outlet who says for
someone else what they can say for
themselves that's why we let pinta Nina
Santa Maria Cortese make her own
arguments we run her own clips and then
address them because we want you to see
what they have to say but there is no
doubt that if you look at these these
social media Titans of Mark Zuckerberg
did you ever watch those those hearings
yeah of course the guy's going to do the
government's bidding at that when he
said before you can't even drink water
no he can't even drink water correctly
it was literally like human beings put
water to lips right yeah Doran in Joe
Rogan we're talking about that but it's
concerning but let me make something
even scarier for you I do agree I do
agree that actually these corporations
are acting as effectively a wing of the
government at this point they're going
to be doing a censoring for them but
let's take it and change it where the
mainstream media social media giants and
the White House and the administration
were - what completely aligned oh gosh
think about that for a second think of
all of this deep platforming that's
going on okay what we're seeing you're
seeing with Alex Jones you've seen
obvious with other conservatives you
talked about that own you've talked
we've talked about what's happened with
us with Facebook how scary would a world
be if this were happening right
now under a Hillary Clinton
administration the point well they're
not doing the government spending does
anyone believe that Facebook Twitter
YouTube is doing Donald Trump's bidding
not exactly but when you look at people
who are working at these giant social
media companies where you talk about
Netflix as well people who were actually
in the Obama administration or people
who were actually advisers to the
Clintons now take the Clintons or take
the Obamas and put them in the White
House make them in charge you were if
you liked this video you first up should
probably seek counseling but you should
subscribe or hit the notification bell
or watch one of these videos that's
playing what the truth is I don't know
what any of that means anymore if you
try and subscribe it's a notification
bell you won't be notified and if you
try to click one of these videos it's
just going to take you to BuzzFeed
boldly fat frauds as they get carried
out of their houses we like to break
down the north wall and they get carried
out in the land well tarp I don't know
what's happening on YouTube I know
what's happening with mug Club ladders
credit.com slash month let me get to
watch The Daily Show one hour every
single day not just clips along with
like 15 other shows for 69 dollars
annually if your student and/or veteran
or military and you get to keep us here
on YouTube for free because we can we
can irritate them by your support it's
worth it right